hi
my name's holly ellis and i'm a clinical
scientist
in genomics at the northwest genomic
laboratory hub
based in liverpool i'm going to be
delivering this presentation alongside
my colleague hannah stevens
who is a trainee clinical scientist at
the same lab
this presentation is entitled gpyg
testing pharmacogenomics in a clinical
setting
throughout this presentation we will
provide some background information on
the use of fluoropyramidine
chemotherapies
and how dpt deficiency can lead to
toxicity to this type of treatment
we will highlight the need for
pharmacogenomic testing prior to
treatment
and discuss how we've implemented this
service into clinical practice
we will share some of our results so far
and hopefully we will highlight the
importance
of pharmacogenomic testing in a clinical
setting
so just for some background information
in america nearly five hundred thousand
cancer patients
each year are treated with chemotherapy
containing fluoro pyrimidines
such as capacitor bean and fluorouracil
otherwise known as 5fu this is the gold
standard treatment
for a variety of cancers including
colorectal
breast head and neck pancreatic and
gastric
floral uracils work as anti-metabolites
which prevent cell proliferation
they primarily inhibit the enzyme
thymitally synthase
blocking the thyme with the information
required for dna synthesis
dna therefore cannot be repaired and
replicated
so cells can no longer proliferate
after administration a small proportion
around five percent of the five fu is
converted
intracellularly to the active cytotoxic
enzymes
but the majority of the administered
dose
is converted into an inactive metabolite
by the gpd enzyme
it's estimated that between 12 and 30
percent
of patients who are given this treatment
suffer from severe toxicity
this can cause diarrhea vomiting cardiac
problems
neurological problems and in some cases
fatality
one of the main reasons as to why many
patients were suffering with toxicity
was due to gpd deficiency
as mentioned in the previous slide the
dpt enzyme is required
to convert 5fu into an inactive
metabolite
that can be safely expelled from the
body
patients with dpd deficiency have
reduced
inactivation of 5 fu thereby increasing
the exposure to active metabolites
and these individuals therefore have an
increased risk of severe
or fatal toxicity the dpt enzyme
is encoded by the dpyd gene
and several variants within this gene
are now known to cause toxicity to 5fu
it is important here to note the
difference between the name of the
protein
dpd and the name of the gene dpyd
some real-life patient stories were
brought to the attention of the media
who revealed examples of those who had
suffered toxicity or fatality after
treatment with five nephew
additionally the families of some
patients who suffered these effects
decided to take legal action against the
trusts that has administered the chemo
claiming that they were not warned about
the potentially life-threatening
consequences
all of this therefore led to an increase
in public pressure for testing
prior to treatment in order to identify
those patients
at increased risk of toxicity
it's really important to note that the
dpydg
is highly polymorphic with many known
variants
the majority of variants within this
gene are not known to affect
protein function however four specific
variants
have been identified that are known to
affect protein function
and lead to an increased risk of
toxicity to 5fu
i have listed these on the slide the
bottom three variants are usually seen
together in cis
and this is known as the hap b3
haplotype
according to the cpic guidelines the
intronic variant
is the likely causative variant
underlying this haplotype
in accordance with the cpic guidelines a
normal tpyc allele
with no variance carries a dpd
activity value of one giving patients
with two
normal alleles a total dpg activity
value of
two each variance listed above
carries a dpt activity of 0 or 0.5
therefore the dpt activity value may
vary
depending on what variant is identified
and whether the patient
is homozygous heterozygous or compound
heterozygous
for two different variants
the total dpd activity value is then
categorized
into a normal intermediate or poor
metabolizer
current guidelines for intermediate
metabolizers
state that the start and dose of
fluoropyramidine-based chemotherapy
should be reduced to 50 percent of the
standard dose
doses then titrated based on toxicity
so if there's no toxicity in the first
two cycles
the dose should be increased to maintain
efficacy
and if the starting dose is not
tolerated the dose should then be
reduced in order to minimize toxicity
by upfront screening of these four
variants prior to treatment
we can identify patients who are
homozygous or heterozygous
and therefore at an increased risk of
toxicity to 5fu
for these patients the salt and dose may
be reduced and titrated based on
toxicity
as described in the previous slide or an
alternative treatment may be used
this will therefore improve patient care
by preventing adverse effects and
hospitalization
which will subsequently lead to an
overall cost saving
this service has now been commissioned
by nhs england
and they released a statement regarding
dpyt testing
earlier this year
the positive impact of this service has
been recognized by the media
and this article was published by the
guardian in december last year
it's evidence that this will have a
positive impact on the care and
treatment
of many patients receiving this type of
chemotherapy
before implementing this test into
routine service
it was really important to engage with
clinicians and service providers to
ensure they understood the importance of
the test
and at which stage in the patient's
journey that this test should be
performed
i.e prior to treatment it was also
important to ensure that clinicians were
aware
of the expected lab turnaround times and
also the limitations of the test
the test that we've implemented in our
lab is a your gene health
genomic testing kit to identify the four
dpyd variants listed on the previous
slides
your gene health was previously known as
a lucid gene diagnostics
this kit allows for easy and quick data
interpretation
and the workflow uses allele specific
amplification refractory mutation system
or arms pcr followed by capillary
electrophoresis
it's important to note that this test
cannot completely exclude toxicity to
5fu
as we're only testing for these four
variants
if we identify a variant then we can
conclude that a patient is at increased
risk
of toxicity but if we do not identify a
variant
we cannot completely exclude toxicity as
they could be or their contribution
factors that we're not testing for
so arms pcr works using a two tube assay
tube a mostly contains primers specific
for the dpy d variants that we're
testing for
and tube b contains primers specific for
the wild type
or normal allele the primers are
fluorescently labeled
so that variant peaks appear in blue and
wild-type peaks appear in green
a patient who is heterozygous for one of
the variants
would therefore have a blue peak
corresponding to the variance and a
green peak
corresponding to the wild type allele
shorthand and repeats or
str markers are also used in the kit to
confirm sample identity
and ensure the same patient's dna is in
tube a
and tube b
the verification of the your gene gpygsa
was relatively quick and easy
and this carries out in line with
international standards
we measured specificity by running
multiple
samples with no known variance and we
measured sensitivity
by running multiple samples with known
variants
the assay correctly identified the known
controls
and therefore reached 100 specificity
and sensitivity
we also investigated measurement
precision reproducibility and robustness
to ensure results were consistent with
different equipment
and different operators
the lab workflow was organized to ensure
results were reported within five days
of the sample arriving in the lab
this is one of the most urgent tests we
perform in the lab
as these patients are awaiting
treatments
upon arrival into the lab samples are
booked into the computer system and
given a unique lab number
the details are reviewed by a genetic
technologist
to ensure the details have been entered
correctly
and the following day samples want to go
dna extraction and are then reviewed by
a scientist
pcr is then set up and left to run
overnight
the next day samples undergo capillary
electrophoresis
and the electropherograms are used for
data analysis
and reporting this seems like a quick
and easy workflow however issues can
arise
if we receive unexpectedly high sample
numbers
as is a limit to the number of samples
that can undergo dna extraction in any
one day
additionally sometimes samples do not
meet the minimum quality acceptance
criteria
so need to be repeated and finally
the lab does not normally operate during
weekends or bank holidays
which can lead to delays in the process
and this has led to ongoing discussions
surrounding a move
towards seven-day working in order to
meet the demands of this service
i'm now going to hand over to my
colleague hannah who will take you
through
some of the results that we've seen so
far
thanks holly i'm going to start with an
example of a normal result
approximately 92 percent of samples
received into the lab
are normal
now as holly said on a previous slide
cpid primer mix a contains primers to
amplify the six
variant alleles detected by the kit
this mix also contains wild type primers
for the detection of one of the normal
alleles which is used as a control for
the amix
both the a and b mixes contain primers
for the identification of two short
tandem repeat markers these markers
should match between the a
and b mixes to show that there has not
been a sample mix-up
cpyd primary mix b contains wild-type
primers to amplify the normal alleles
with the exception
of the normal and primers included in
the a primer mix
this sample met the quality acceptance
quite criteria as
all the peaks are above 500 relative
fluorescent units
all wild type peaks are present and the
short hand and repeat markers match
as no variant peaks were detected this
is an example of a patient with normal
dpd
function who would not require an
fluoropyramidine dose reduction
the next case is an example of a
heterozygous variant detected
this example is the most common variant
detected
the patient has three variants which are
all parts of the hat b3 that holly has
previously mentioned
this patient is heterozygous as the
respective
normal green peaks are still present
although it reduced peak height
even though there are three variant
peaks
this result should be reported as the
variant highlighted at the top of the
side
as this is the functional variant the
functional variant creates a spy site
leading to mis-splicing of an intronic
sequence into the dpyd
messenger rna the other variants
are tagging snips the functional variant
has been found in multiple studies to be
in
perfect linkage with the variant at the
1236
locus however the variant at the
483 locus is not in complete linkage
we have seen several patients who do not
have the 483 variant
these patients would have the same
phenotype as the hack b3
we've also seen several patients
with the 483 variant alone
which current research suggests would
not have a functional effect
so a normal dose of fluoropyrimidine
could be given
as holly previously discussed we use the
cpic guidelines and use activity scores
to decide if patients need floral
pyrimidine dose adjustment
this patient is heterozygous for hat b3
and the normal allele has an activity
value of 1
and the variant allele has an activity
value of 0.5
therefore the total activity score is
1.5 and the patient is a gpyd
intermediate metabolizer with increased
risk of chloropyrimidine toxicity
that requires a 50 dose reduction
even if this patient had one
non-functional variant
and a total score of one the treatment
strategy would be the same
all heterozygous variants require a 50
dose reduction
whether they score 1 or 1.5
next is an example of a homozygous
variant
we've only had one homozygous patient
since testing has begun
so these are very rare
the patient has a single blue peak and
no green peak
at the 1905 locus
therefore they are homozygous for this
variant
both markers for this variant are
included in the a mix
therefore there are still five normal
allele peaks present in the b
mix this variant
is predicted to result in a
non-functional cpd protein
and as the patient has two copies the
patient's activity score is zero
so the patient has no functional alleles
of the dpyd
gene as a result of this this patient
would be unable to metabolize
pyrimidines
and would have a very high risk of
severe or fatal toxicity when treated
with floral pyrimidines
this patient is dpyd poor metabolizer
with complete gpd
deficiency blood pyrimidine use should
be avoided in this patient complete cpd
deficiency is very rare and is usually
associated with symptoms such as
intellectual disability motor
retardation and convulsions
but as was the case with this patient it
can also be
asymptomatic
the next example is a case where
compounds heterozygous variants were
detected
detection of two cpyb variants is rare
and occurs in only about 0.2 percent of
patients
this patient has perhaps b3 and a
variant as the 1679 locus
and is compound heterozygous from this
assay we cannot be sure if the variant
is in trans
with one variant on each allele or
insists with one allele with two
variants and one functional allele
we assume it's in trans and the worst
case scenario for the
dosage recommendation
this patient has two variants that are
assumed to be untrans
with no fully functional allele the
activity score is 0.5
the patient is a dpyd poor metabolizer
with
increased risk of severe
chloropyrimidine toxicity
in this patient use subfloor pyrimidines
should have been avoided
but the cpic guideline states that if
there is no alternative
a much lower dose of fluoropyrimidine
could be used
but requires very careful titration and
monitoring
the next case is also a patient with
compound heterozygous but they have
different variants
this patient has to have b3 but this
time with a different
variant at the 2846 locus
this results in a decreased function
dpyd
rather than a non-functional dpyc allele
in this case the total activity score is
1 as both alleles are partially
functional
therefore this patient is a dpyd
intermediate metabolizer rather than a
poor metabolizer
this patient can be treated with floral
pyrimidines but at a
fifty percent reduced dose
this is the same recommendation as
patients who are heterozygous for one
variant
this highlights the importance to check
the cpic guidelines for compound
heterozygotes
as different combinations of variants
require different treatment strategies
next i will discuss how we investigate
incidental findings
although we test for the common variants
included in the nhs
england recommendations other variants
can affect cpd functions
this can result in the detection of
incidental findings which require a
further investigation
since we started testing we have
observed the double peak for one of the
wild-type markers for three patients
this suggests a small deletion or
insertion for one of the alleles
these findings require investigation
using sanger sequencing to fully
elucidate the variant
as it could suggest the presence of a
pathogenic variant
deletions or insertions result in sanger
sequencing with the mixed trace
however a mixed trace doesn't always
mean that the variant would have
functional significance
especially when a variant occurs in an
intronic region
classification of the three variants
identified as incidental findings was
undertaken
following the criteria set out by the
personalized medicine commission
expert panel the top two variants were
within
intronic regions and were not reported
in databases or the literature
in cellular code studies did not suggest
that these variants would disrupt spy
sites
therefore variant analysis classified
these two variants to be of uncertain
significance
however this variant resulted in a
frameshift in exon 11
and the addition of a stop codon that
would terminate amino acid translation
therefore a novel actionable variant
that was likely pathogenic was
identified through investigating and
incidental finding
this shows the importance of following
up all incidental findings which require
federal investigation
figures generated on the 19th of march
2021
show that we have now tested over 2 500
patients
just over 8 of these were found to have
at least one of the four variants in
cpyd that are known to cause toxicity to
flora pyrimidines
that equates to a total of 214 patients
for whom we have identified a variant
prior to treatment
without this test these patients would
have been given the standard dose of
chemotherapy
which would have likely caused toxicity
the implementation of this test has
therefore already been successful in
preventing serious harm
or even death in 214 individuals
we are now receiving around 100 samples
a week of
20 samples a day from patients across
across the northwest of england
if you would like any further
information on the dpyd service then
please check out holly's youtube channel
the scout scientist
she uses this platform to encourage more
young people to follow in her footsteps
and
pursue a career in science
she has recently produced an episode on
dpyd testing where she films the entire
laboratory process from a blood sample
arriving in the lab to the report going
out
so if you're interested in finding out
more then please watch the video
and subscribe to her channel
in summary we hope we have fulfilled our
learning objectives
and highlighted the importance of dpyd
testing prior to treatment with
fluorochromatin chemotherapies
we hope you now understand how the
service has been implemented for use in
routine clinical practice
we would like to acknowledge the work of
all the staff at the northwest
genomics laboratory hub who were
involved in the dpyd service
as well as the team at eurogene health
providing the dpyd testing kit that
we're currently using for service
delivery
we would finally like to say thank you
for listening and we're happy to answer
any questions